qu'est-ce qu'on fait un mort à bord d'un
avion par les matches suivants vous
allez panique et les autres attendent et
je dois changer de siège tenez moi ta
bonté mais témoin dans les lavabos les
toilettes
j'allais countryman je le connaissais
c'était mon voisin la langue notre père
demandé de vous dire quelque chose et
c'est gabriel heureux de vous connaître
juste super stressé parce que tout ça
c'est complètement nouveau pour moi et
moi regarde ça te fait fantasmer de d
une femme en détresse dans un pays
exotique
joe beauté et vous vous êtes dit que je
suis majeur les toits mike et moi on
était marié non je relis pas était
plutôt jusqu'à ce que la mort sait pas
quand tu perds la personne tout je suis
comme ça de l ex
charles une fille à poil
celle où je peux trouver caby
c'est une règle je profite donc tu peux
l'un d'eux et tout peut finir dans un
bar de soirée
est-ce que tu as conscience du genre
john key
plutôt joli coup
ici cette histoire tout ça c'est une
entente
j'ai vu la cassette tu sais de quoi je
parle
est ce que tu es amoureux
rouge à trois jours du condor
woolf le gt passage
vaut mieux que tu partages
doweik une heure peut remercier
si chômeurs sera pas un mot
je me classe comme